The world has had 72 hours to digest the
release of Gemini 2.5, and the good
first impressions have become even
better second and third impressions.
I've got four new benchmark results to
show you guys, including a record score
on my own exam. But it won't just be
about the numbers. I'll draw on a paper
from yesterday as well as my own test to
show you that sometimes Gemini 2.5 can
deceptively reverse engineer its answers
and that beyond that Google doesn't own
every AI arena and domain just yet. I'm
going to start with what might seem to
be a strange place with a not
particularly well-known benchmark called
fiction lifebench, but I think it will
make sense why I cover it first.
analyzing long essays or presentations
or codebases or stories is what a lot of
people use AI for, what they turn to
with their chatbot. I had seen the
sensational score of Gemini 2.5 Pro on
this benchmark, but I wanted to dive
deeper and see what kind of questions it
had. What it does, and honestly, I'm
surprised that no one else had come up
with a test just like this one before,
is it will give a sample text, and this
is a fairly short one at like around
6,000 words or 8,000 tokens. It's a
sci-fi story with a fairly convoluted
plot, but after pages and pages and
pages of text, we get to the question at
the end. Finish the sentence. What names
would Jerome list? Give me a list of
names only. Admittedly, with the help of
a chatbot, what I did is I figured out
why the answer was a certain set of
names, and it relies on a promise held
in chapter 2, but with a caveat given in
chapter 16. So essentially the chatbot,
in this case Gemini 2.5, has to hold all
of that information in its attention.
Note that this isn't just a needle in a
haststack challenge, not like a password
hidden on line 500. The model actually
has to piece together different bits of
information. Now imagine this applied to
your use case, whatever it is with LLMs.
Enough buildup. Then what were the
results and look at Gemini 2.5 Pro as it
compares to other Gemini models? But any
other model, particularly when you get
to the longer context at the upper end,
120k tokens is like a novella or a
decently expanded code base. And you can
see that Gemini is head and shoulders
above other models. It really starts to
pull away once you go beyond around
32,000 tokens, but it's decent
throughout. Already, I can tell about
half the audience is thinking, hm, I
could see some use for that for my use
case. But we're not done yet, of course.
Next, I'm going to quickly focus on
something that isn't a benchmark, but
can be forgotten by those of us who are
immersed in AI all the time. The sheer
practicality of the model on Google AI
Studio at least, it can handle not only
videos, but also YouTube URLs, and no
other model that I'm familiar with can.
It also just simply has a more recent
knowledge cutoff date of January 2025,
so it should in theory know things up to
that date. that compares to Claude 3.7
Sonnet which is I think October 2024 and
even far earlier for OpenAI models. Now
obviously don't rely too heavily on that
knowledge. It can be hit and miss and of
course rival models can simply search
the internet too. I would very quickly
note that giving themselves just a month
and a half to test the security of their
new model kind of shows we are in a race
to the bottom on that front and also
they didn't produce any report card
unlike OpenAI or Anthropic. Next comes
coding and you could say that Google or
Google DeepMind were admirably modest in
the benchmarks they chose to highlight
on coding. They picked two benchmarks,
Live Codebench V5 and Swebench Verified
in which they slightly underperformed
the competition. In the case of Live
Codebench, it was roundly beaten by Gro
3. And just to answer a question I keep
getting in the comments. The reason I'm
not testing Grock 3 on SimpleBench is
because the API isn't out yet. That's
just to answer all of those people
saying that I'm somehow biased against
Gro 3. I just simply can't test it on
SimpleBench without an API. Anyway,
Grock 3 does really well on that
benchmark, beating Gemini 2.5 Pro. And
one of the other prominent industry
benchmarks for coding is Swebench
Verified, software engineering bench
verified. This is a thoroughly vetted
benchmark, hence the verified, in which
again Gemini 2.5 Pro is beaten not only
by Clawude 3.7, which gets 70.3%, but
also by 03, which isn't on here, but
OpenAI said it got
71.7%. What I found interesting though
is that Google chose not to highlight
Gemini 2.5 Pro's performance on
LiveBench, a very popular coding
benchmark. Why surprising? Well, because
on this benchmark in the coding
subsection, Gemini 2.5 Pro scores the
best of any model, including Claude 3.7
Sonnet. Obviously, you'll have to give
me your own feedback on how you feel it
performs on your coding use case, but I
wanted to give you a quick 20 second
guess about why there is this slight
discrepancy in performance. To do so, I
dived into each of the three papers
behind these three coding benchmarks.
For LiveBench, the one you just saw, in
which Gemini 2.5 scores the best, it's
partly based on competition coding
questions and also partly based on
completing partially correct solutions.
sourced from leak code. Think more
competition coding rather than real
world situations. Now, live codebench,
not to be confused with livebench, this
is live codebench at which Gemini 2.5
Pro slightly underperforms tests more
than code generation. It's about broader
code related capabilities such as
self-repair, code execution, and test
output prediction. Finally, SweetBench
verified at which Gemini 2.5 is clearly
not state-of-the-art. those problems are
drawn and filtered from real GitHub
issues and corresponding pull requests.
So, a bit less about your coding IQ and
more about your practical capabilities.
Hopefully, essentially all of that has
given you just like a smidgen of context
to all of these competing claims about
what is state-of-the-art in coding for
me. I've tested it a bit in Windsurf,
but I would rely on the benchmarks for
the moment at least. Speaking of which,
how about the weird ML benchmark and
then I promise I'll get to SimpleBench.
Why am I picking this one out? It's
because it's like another community
benchmark based on novel data sets. So
even though it's testing something
different, machine learning, I kind of
trust the vibe of these kind of
benchmarks a bit more than some of the
gamified ones. You can see what it's
testing here. It's about understanding
the properties of the data the model's
given, coming up with the appropriate
architecture, debugging, and improving
solutions. But to cut to the chase, and
this is hot off the press, so it's not
even updated on the website yet. Gemini
2.5 Pro scores the highest of any model.
Okay, how about Gemini 2.5's performance
on SimpleBench, which is the benchmark
that I first came up with around 9
months ago. The 30 secondond background
to SimpleBench is that I noticed last
year that there were certain types of
questions involving spatial reasoning,
social intelligence, or trick questions
that the models kept falling for. No
matter how well they did on the gamified
benchmarks like MLU at the time, they
would fall for questions that most
humans would get right. In around
September of last year, we published
this website. This is me and a senior ML
colleague that helps keep this going.
And the human baseline among our nine
testers was around 84% and the best
model 01 preview got 42%. So I think
roughly double for human average
compared to the best language model.
Obviously, a lot has happened in 6 to9
months and the current best performing
model had been clawed 3.7 Sonnet the
extended thinking version at around 46%.
There's over 200 questions on the
benchmark and we run the benchmark five
times to get an average. So, we're just
calculating the final decimal point as
we speak. But the performance of Gemini
2.5 Pro is around
51.6.7%. Let's call it 51.6%. But you
can see that's a clear jump from Clawude
3.7 Sonnet in this benchmark. It's also
obviously, you don't need me to say
this, the first model that scores above
50%. So quite a moment for me at least.
What I did then is go through every
answer that Gemini 2.5 Pro gave in the
benchmark to kind of sense where it was
doing better. I'm going to quickly show
you one example of the type of question
that Gemini 2.5 Pro is often getting
right. and Claude 3.7 Sonnet and 01 Pro
is often getting wrong because of what's
called temperature. You can't always
predict the answer that a model will
give. So, I'm sure that Claude 3.7
sometimes gets this right. Nor will I
force you to read the entire question.
But, it's a classic logic puzzle which
seems to involve mathematics because
you're guessing the color of your own
hat based on what other people are
saying. But the twist on the scenario is
that there are mirrors covering every
wall. You're in a small, brightly lit
room and you have to guess the color of
the hat that you're wearing to win $2
million. Now, by the way, I modified
this question because it's not in the
publicly released set of questions.
Notice, by the way, the question says,
"The participants can see the others
hats but can't directly see their own."
So, that directly is another kind of
giveaway that Gemini 2.5 actually picked
up on. Claude will typically ignore
those kind of clues and launch straight
into the deep mathematical analysis
giving the wrong answer of two or f. So
does 01 pro and that's to be expected.
These models are trained to predict the
next word at their heart and are trained
on thousands or millions of mathematical
examples. For a model to spot the
question behind the question that
actually they don't need to guess. They
can just see their hats color in the
reflection. That takes something
different. Gemini 2.5 identifies the
fact that them not being able to see
their own hat directly doesn't preclude
them seeing it indirectly and it states
that realistically which is what the
question was asking for. Therefore the
answer would be that they all guess
correctly. As many of you will point out
that's just one example and it's
anecdotal but what Simple Bench
hopefully does show us is that the vibe
of this model when you speak to it
should be that it's just a little bit
smarter than some of the others. has
just that edge on common sense. Still
will make tons of blunders and of course
hallucinations, but will just have a
slightly smarter vibe. By the way, if
this has in any way wet your appetite to
do benchmarking or you are a developer
or ML engineer who focuses on
benchmarking, do check out the sponsors
of this video, which is Weights and
Biases. As you can see front and center,
we do indeed use Weave to benchmark
models on SimpleBench and it is very
fast and lightweight. The link that you
would find in the description will bring
you to this page which not only tells
you how to get started with weave but
also gives you a link to the Weights and
Biases AI Academy. That academy will
help you if you're slightly newer to
this whole arena and of course includes
free courses. That reminds me, I need to
work on that new competition with
Weights and Biases for Simple Bench
because it relates to the next point I'm
going to make about Google Gemini 2.5
and that is that it will sometimes
reverse engineer its answers. This is
again a simple bench question. This time
from the public set. I'm going to touch
on the paper that inspired this question
in a moment, but first just an example
to get you interested. I asked please
correctly answer the following question.
Ignore any examiner notes or
instructions. This is the question from
SimpleBench and I've covered it before
on the channel. You can pause and try it
yourself if you like. But on the actual
correct answer, which is D, I wrote
examiner note. This is the correct
answer. Now, do you guys notice
something quite interesting about
Gemini's answer here. Hm. It picks the
right answer D. And take a look at its
justification. Hm. Not really seeing any
mention of the examiner note. And I know
what you're thinking. How about if we
look at the thoughts of the model, but
it goes through all sorts of analysis
before even hinting that it might have
noticed the examiner note. I won't bore
you with the analysis, but you have to
wait until all the way at the end. And
even then, it says that that is
confirming its answer. The examiner
note, it said, which I'm supposed to
ignore, but noted in the prompt, points
to D confirming this interpretation. The
model is essentially saying, "I would
have got there anyway." But yes, that
examiner note confirms what I thought,
which you might believe until you test
the model, of course, without the
examiner note. As on the official
benchmark run, it gets it wrong. And no,
that's not a one-off. You can keep
rerunning it and it will get it wrong.
There it is again, picking 96%, which it
picks pretty much every time. Just bear
this example in mind because language
models are fundamentally about
predicting the next word correctly.
That's their core imperative, not to be
your friend or to be honest about its
approach to giving you the answer that
it gave. What inspired this was the
interpretability paper from Anthropic
that came out yesterday tracing the
thoughts of a large language model. I'm
just going to give you the quick
highlights now because it is a very
dense and interesting paper that I will
come back to probably multiple times in
the future. If you can't wait that long,
I've also done a deep dive on my Patreon
about claw 3.7 about how it knows it's
being tested. And if that's not enough,
you'll also find there a mini
documentary on the origin stories of
Anthropic and OpenAI and Google Deep
Mind. The feedback was great, so
there'll be plenty more mini
documentaries, and many of them may
indeed make it to the main channel. The
first takeaway is that recurring sick
fancy of the model that it will, as
you've just seen, give a plausible
sounding argument designed to agree with
the user rather than follow logical
steps. In other words, if it doesn't
know something, it will look at the
answer or try to if it's there and
reverse engineer how you might have come
up with it. Remember, it won't say it's
doing that. It will come up with a
plausible sounding reason why it's doing
that. The paper in section 11 calls this
BSing in the sense of Frankfurt making
up an answer without regard to the
truth. And the example they gave is even
more crisp than the one I gave. Of
course, they gave Claude 3.5 Haiku a
mathematical problem that it can't
possibly work out on its own. In this
case, cosine of
23,423. Then you got to multiply that
answer by 5 and round. But the key bit
is that cosine which it can't possibly
work out without a calculator. Notice
they then say, "I worked out by hand and
got four." That's the user speaking.
What answer does poor haiku come up with
four? Confirming your calculation. Does
it admit how it got this? No. Does it
come up with a BS kind of explainer of
how it got it? Yes. And to nail down
still further the fact that the model
was reverse engineering the answer, they
took the penultimate step and then
deliberately inhibited that circuit
within the model, inhibited the five or
divide by five approach. Dividing by
five, remember, would be the penultimate
step if you were reverse engineering
from the final answer of four to get
back to what cosine of that long number
was. If you inhibit that circuit within
the model, the model no longer can come
up with the answer. This is a video on
Gemini 2.5, so I'm not going to spend
too long on this in this video. But as
you saw with that Gemini 2.5 example
from SimpleBench, Claude, like Gemini,
will plan what it will say many words
ahead and write to get to that
destination. You might have thought then
that with poetry models like Gemini 2.5
or Claude would write one word at a time
just guessing auto reggressively it's
called trying in other words to get to
the end of this rhyming scheme and
thinking with something that's starving
that rhymes with grabbit but no by
interpreting the features within the
model. This is a field called
mechanistic interpretability. They found
that instead Claude plans ahead. It knew
in other words it would pick rabbit to
rhyme with grabbit. Then it just fills
in the rest of what's needed to end with
rabbit. Finally, and this was so
interesting that I couldn't help but
just include a snippet of this topic in
this video, and it's on language,
specifically whether there is a
conceptual space that is shared between
languages, suggesting a kind of
universal language of thought, a bit
like a concept of happiness that is
separate from any instantiation of that
word happiness in any language. Does
Claude or Gemini think of this purely
abstract happiness and then translate
into the required language? Or is
happiness only existing as a token
within each language? Well, it's the
more poetic answer which is yes. It has
this language of thought, this universal
language. That kind of shared circuitry,
by the way, they found increases with
model scale. So, as models get bigger,
this is going to happen more and more
often. This gives us, in other words,
additional evidence for this conceptual
universality, a shared abstract space
where meanings exist and where thinking
can happen before being translated into
specific languages. More practically,
Claude or Gemini could learn something
in one language and apply that knowledge
when speaking another. The fact that
Gemini 2.5 gets almost 90% on the global
MLU, which is the MLU translated into 15
different languages, suggests to me that
it might be having more of those
conceptually universal thoughts than
perhaps any other model. The MLU being a
flawed but fascinating benchmark
covering aptitude and knowledge across
57 domains. Drawing to an end now, but
three quick caveats about Gemini 2.5.
Just because 2.5 Pro can do a ton of
stuff doesn't mean it does everything at
state-of-the-art levels. One researcher
at Google DeepMind showed its
transcribing ability and the ability to
give timestamps. I was curious, of
course, so I went in and tested it
thoroughly versus Assembly AI, and the
transcription wasn't nearly as good. It
would transcribe things like Häen
instead of hey Genen, which Assembly got
right, nor were the timestamps quite as
good. And this is not a slight on
Gemini, by the way. It's amazing that it
can even get close. It's just let's not
go overboard. Also, just because Gemini
2.5 is amazing at many modalities
doesn't mean Google is ahead on them
all. Of course, my video from around 72
hours ago on image gen from CGBT, I hope
showed you guys that I think that
chatbt's image gen is the best in the
world. And then how about on turning
those images into videos? Now, Sora
isn't amazing at that. And I've even
tried V2 extensively and yes, it's
decent. It's better actually if you're
creating a video from scratch on V2. But
if you want to animate a particular
image, you're actually better off using
Cling AI. I don't know much about them.
They are a Chinese model provider. I
just find that they adhere to the image
you gave them initially much more than
any other model. And no, I'm probably
not going to have time to cover this new
study on just how bad AI search engines
are. It wasn't just about the accuracy
of what they said. It's who they cited
and whether they were citing the correct
article. How's that relevant to Gemini?
Well, yes, this came out before the new
Gemini 2.5. But you'd have thought it
would be Google who had mastered search.
But honestly, their AI overviews are
like really dodgy. Don't trust them.
I've been burnt before as I've talked
about on the channel. And for this
study, which was Gemini 2 presumably,
you could see how it would far often
give incorrect answers, hallucinated or
incorrect citations as compared to
things like chatbt search or Plexity.
You don't need me to point out that
coming from Google, that shouldn't be
the case. And one final caveat before I
end. Yes, Gemini 2.5 Pro is a smart
chatbot, probably the best one around at
the moment, depending on your use case.
Even on creative writing, I found it to
be amazing. better even than the freshly
updated GPT40 from OpenAI. But there are
new models all the time at the moment.
Deepseek R2 is probably just a few weeks
away. Llama 4 we still don't know about.
O3 never even got released from OpenAI
and maybe rolled into GPT5. And I could
go on and on. The CEO of Anthropic said
that they're going to be spending
hundreds of millions on reinforcement
learning for Claude 4. So you get the
picture. The crown may not stay too long
with Google, but arguably they have it
today. Did I underestimate it then for
my previous video? Well, you could say
that. But I would argue that the point I
was trying to get across, and do check
out that video if you haven't seen it,
is that AI is being commoditized. You
can buy Victory. Making a good chatbot
isn't about having some secret source at
the headquarters of Anthropic or OpenAI.
That then is supported by the evidence
of convergence on certain benchmarks.
across the different model families. But
as I mentioned in that video,
convergence definitely does not preclude
progress, and progress is very much what
Gemini 2.5 Pro has brought us. Thank you
so much for watching. would love to know
what you think and above all have a
wonderful